uh good afternoon i'm matthew spalding
associate vice president dean of
educational programs for hillsdale
college here in washington d.c
welcome to the allen p kirby center for
constitutional studies and citizenship
an extension of hillsdale college's
campus and its teaching mission here in
the nation's capital
in a self-governing regime elections are
great opportunities to clarify the
principles we hold in common
uh for instance religious liberty
perhaps the central
question our central uh most important
principle
of the american founding not as a matter
of toleration but in matters of right
yet today we are deeply concerned about
protecting free exercise
thus we are concerned about the supreme
court and dominations to the court
likewise immigration
we believe that all men are created
equal but we are also a particular
nation
it is us who determine who and who is
who is not a citizen
requirements of citizenship no one has a
right to immigrate here without the
consent to the american people
well when you combine those two issues
and two principles behind them
you have a vexing question especially
when it comes to the question of islam
and immigration a particular question
that has been raised in the current
election cycle
and it's not as simply a matter of
religion raises
questions of terrorism because islam or
at least
elements of it seem to be less than
friendly to the religious liberty of
other faiths
but that took all together and we
question of domestic terrorism in the
united states
and as a result our speaker will argue
we face a threat of domestic terrorism
greater than that we've faced since 9
11.
to introduce our speaker we once again
asked one of our current students
christiana mark she's a junior george
washington fellow
majoring in politics communications and
she's currently here on the washington
hillsdale internship program this
semester
she's splitting her time between
heritage foundation's daily signal
and working with fox news
today we are honored to be joined by mr
andrew mccarthy mr mccarthy is a senior
fellow at the national review institute
a contributing editor at the national
review and a well-known commentator on
legal
national security and political affairs
he also writes regularly for pj media
and the news criterion
mr mccarthy previously served as the
chief assistant u.s attorney in new york
and while serving in this capacity he
led the prosecution
of 12 jihadists who are responsible for
terror attacks against the united states
these included the 1993 world trade
center bombing
and a plot to destroy the monuments in
new york city
after the 9 11 attacks mr mccarthy
supervised the u.s attorney's command
post
near ground zero and later he served as
an advisor to the deputy secretary of
defense
mr mccarthy is the author of new york
times best-selling books
willful blindness a memoir of jihad
published in 2008 and the great jihad
how islam and the left sabotage america
published in 2010.
his latest books include spring fever
the illusion of islamic democracy
published in 2013
and faithful faithless execution
building a political case for obama's
impeachment
which was published in june of last year
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming
mr andrew mccarthy
well thank you very much it's a it's a
honor to
be back again at hillsdale it's uh
second or third time i've uh
i've done this and it's been a delight
each time and it's always uh it's always
great to return
um in in 1993
i was a seasoned federal prosecutor but
i only knew about as much about islam as
anyone with a reasonably good education
in the united states knew which is to
say
not much consequently when i was
assigned to lead the prosecution
of a terrorist cell that had bombed the
world trade center and was actively
plotting an even more devastating attack
an attack on the
lincoln and holland tunnels uh the fbi's
headquarters in lower manhattan
and the u.n complex on the east river
i had no trouble believing what we were
saying at that time
as a government which happens to be the
same thing we're saying as a government
now
to wit we should read nothing into the
fact
that all of the men waging a terrorist
war against our country
were muslims it was just happenstance
their actions were not representative of
any religion
or any mainstream belief system and to
the extent they were purporting
to justify their atrocities by citations
to islamic scripture
they were lying they were twisting and
perverting one of the world's great
religions
a religion that far from commanding war
actually encouraged peace
alas this fairy tale could not withstand
examination
and unlike uh commentators and
government press secretaries
i would actually have to examine it
prosecutors don't get to announce things
they have to prove things
to ordinary common sense americans are
jurors
who want to be satisfied not only about
what happened
but about why it happened before they
will convict people of serious crimes
one of the first things i learned
concern the leader of the terror cell
omar abdul rahman who is infamously
known as the blind sheikh
he was the man our government was
portraying as a wanton killer
who was lying about islam preaching that
it summoned muslims to jihad
holy war what i learned was that
far from a lunatic he was a globally
renowned scholar
a doctor of islamic jurisprudence
graduated from al-azhar university
in cairo the seat of sunni learning
since the 10th century his area of
academic expertise
was sharia islamic law
i immediately began to wonder why
american government officials from
president bill clinton and attorney
general janet reno
on down officials who had absolutely no
background in muslim doctrine
or muslim culture believed they knew
more about islam
than the blind sheikh did something else
dawned on me
the blind shake was not only well blind
uh he was also beset by many other
medical handicaps
that seemed relevant after all terrorism
is hard work
yet here was a man utterly incapable of
doing
anything useful for a terrorist
organization
couldn't build a bomb couldn't carry out
an assassination couldn't hijack a plane
um yet he was the unquestioned leader
of the terror cell and why was that
it was because of his mastery of islamic
doctrine
obviously there was more to his
interpretation of islam
and our government was conceding
of course defendants do not have to
testify at criminal trials
but they also have a right to testify if
they choose to
so even though the blind shake
ultimately did not take the stand during
our nine-month trial
i had to prepare for that possibility
raised an irish catholic in the bronx i
was not foolish enough to believe
that i could get into a debate about
muslim theology
against the doctor of islamic
jurisprudence
but i did think that if what we were
saying as a government was true
that he was lying that he was perverting
the doctrine that he was perverting
islam
that there must be two or three places
where i could really nail it
or i could say you told your followers
this
and the doctrine says otherwise
so we went to school on the blind shakes
copious
body of work his many speeches his books
and what we found was alarming whenever
he quoted the quran
or other sources of islamic scripture he
quoted it accurately
now you might be able to argue that
he took scripture out of context or gave
an incomplete account of it
over years of studying islam i've since
learned that this is not a particularly
persuasive argument
but let's concede for purposes of this
discussion that it is a tolerable claim
still the inconvenient fact remain
the blind sheikh certainly was not lying
about islam when he said the scriptures
command that muslims strike terror into
the
hearts of the enemies of islam the
scriptures backed him up
when he said that allah enjoined all
muslims to wage jihad
until islamic law was established
throughout the world
the scriptures backed him up when he
said islam directed muslims not to take
jews and christians as their friends
the scriptures backed him up now
you could counter that there are other
ways of construing the scriptures
you could contend that these
exhortations to violence and hatred
should be
contextualized as they say that is that
they were only meant for their time and
place in the 7th century
and they do not have modern relevance
again
i would caution that there are
compelling arguments against that manner
of interpreting islamic scripture
the point however is that what you'd be
arguing is just that
an interpretation the fact that there
are multiple ways of construing
islam hardly makes the blind shakes
literal construction
wrong indeed the blunt fact of the
matter
is that in this contest of competing
interpretations
it is the jihadists who seem to be
making sense because literalism
is on their side it's often the
reformers who sound like they are
dancing on the head of the pen
for our present purposes however the
point is that the blind sheikh summons
to jihad
was undeniably rooted in a coherent
interpretation of islamic doctrine
he was not perverting islam he was if
anything shining a light on the need to
reform islam
another point obvious but inconvenient
is that islam
simply is not a religion of peace
there are ways of interpreting islam
that could make it something other than
a call to war
but even these benign constructions do
not make it a call to peace
verses like fight those who believe not
in allah
and fight and slay the pagans wherever
ye find them
and seize them and beleaguer them and
lie and wait for them in every stratagem
of war
are not peaceful injunctions no matter
how one
contextualizes them
there was another disturbing aspect of
our trial against the blind sheikh and
11 other members of his jihadist cell
the character witnesses who testified
for the defense
most of these people were muslims
authentically moderate peaceful muslim
americans who would no more become a
terrorist than any other american than
any of us gathered
in this room here's the thing though
every now and then a question about
islamic doctrine would come up in the
testimony
what does jihad mean what is sharia
how might sharia apply to a certain
situation
how would these moderate peaceful
muslims reply
what they would generally say was that
they wouldn't be competent
to ask to answer such a question for an
answer like that they'd say
you'd need to speak to him at which
point they would point to the homicidal
maniac sitting in the corner
of my courtroom
now understand there was no doubt in
anyone
anyone's mind what the blindshake was on
trial for
and there was no doubt in anyone's mind
that he was terrorist after all he
bragged about being a terrorist
yet that fact did not disqualify him in
the minds of these moderate peaceful
muslims
from rendering authoritative opinions on
the meaning of core tenets of their
beliefs
belief system mind you no one is saying
that they would follow the blind shake
into terrorism into violent jihad
but the point is no one was discrediting
him
either from the standpoint of these
muslims
his years of study and mastery of sharia
made him a trustworthy guide to what
islamic doctrine means to what islam
means
now i have a confession to make none of
this should have been a revelation to me
it is not like western civilization had
no experience
with islamic supremacism what we today
call
islamist ideology the belief that sharia
must govern a society
let's consider two of our icons i would
not come to hillsdale
and chance running into the incomparable
larry arn
without being prepared to say something
about winston churchill
he had encountered islam as a young man
serving in the british army
both in the border region between
afghanistan and pakistan
and in khartoum in the sudan
these places continued to this day to be
cauldrons of islamic supremacism and
terrorism
ever observant churchill wrote how
dreadful
are the curses which mohammedanism lays
on its voters
besides the fanatical frenzy which is as
dangerous in a man
as hydrophobia in a dog there is this
fearful fatalistic apathy improving
habits
slovenly systems of agriculture sluggish
methods of commerce
and the insecurity of property exists
wherever the followers of the prophet
live or rule a degraded sensualism
deprives this life
of its grace and refinement the next
of its dignity and sanctity the fact
that in
muhammadan law every woman must belong
to some man
as his absolute property either as a
child
a wife or a concubine must delay the
final extinction of slavery
until the faith of islam has ceased to
be a great power
among men churchill was prescient in
this
slavery was still practiced officially
in many islamic countries until very
recently
is still practice the practice
unofficially in some
and as the headlines daily remind us is
practiced
unabashedly by jihadists like rape
it is a weapon of war
i distinguish between islam and muslims
it is objectively important to do that
but i also have a personal reason
the first muslims i met when i began
working on national security cases were
not terrorists to the contrary they were
pro-american patriots
who helped us infiltrate terrorist cells
disrupt mass murder attacks
and gather the evidence needed to
convict jihadists
we have an obligation to our national
security to understand our enemies
but we also have an obligation to our
principles not to convict by association
not to confound our islamist enemies
with our muslim friends
churchill appreciated this distinction
as well
individual muslims he stressed may show
splendid
qualities thousands become brave and
loyal soldiers of the queen
all know how to die the problem was not
the people he concluded
it was the doctrine the influence of the
religion paralyzes social development
of those who follow it you've heard no
stronger retrograde force
exists in the world far from being
moribund he said
mohammedanism is a militant and
proselytizing faith
winston churchill and the blind sheikh
would not have agreed on the effects of
islam
but when it comes to the essence of
islam
they were in concurrence it is a
militant
and proselytizing faith
what about islamic law here it's useful
to turn to yet another icon
robert jackson a giant figure in
american law and politics
fdr's attorney general justice of the
supreme court
and chief prosecutor of the war crimes
trials at nuremberg
in 1955 justice jackson penned the
forward to a book called
law in the middle east unlike
contemporary american officials
justice jackson thought the law of the
middle east
sharia was a subject worthy of close
study
he was not one to take thoughtless
repetition of the mantra
religion of peace as his guide
here's what he concluded in any broad
sense
islamic law offers the american lawyer a
study
in dramatic contrasts even casual
acquaintance and superficial knowledge
all that most of us at bench or bar will
ever be able to acquire
reveal that its striking features
relative to our law
are not likenesses but inconsistencies
not similarities but contrarities
in its source its scope and its
sanctions the law of the middle east
is the antithesis of western law
today remarkably academics who could not
hold a candle to justice jackson
insist that islam and western legal
principles are seamlessly compatible
that they can co-exist as they are said
to do for example in the constitution
the united states government helped
write for post-taliban afghanistan
a constitution under which muslim
converts to christianity
have been subjected to capital trials or
apostasy
despite the new afghan constitution's
soaring tropes about human rights
the document makes islam the state
religion and sharia
a principle source of law under sharia
apostasy from islam is the most grievous
of offenses
warranting capital punishment to avoid
further embarrassment to the western
nations propping it up
the afghan government allowed the
apostates to be whisked off to europe
before the death penalty could be
imposed
sharia in fact rejects core premises of
our constitutional democracy
including the foundational assumption
that the people
are free to rule themselves in islam
all are required to submit to allah's
law
no surprise here contrary to president
obama's insistence during a recent visit
to a mosque in baltimore
islam does not mean peace it means
submission
peace arrives only after conquest
sharia rejects freedom of speech
punishing perceived blasphemy
just as it punishes apostasy sharia
suffocates liberty and privacy
not content to condemn homosexuality it
prescribes the death penalty
sharia rejects equality between men and
women
between muslims and non-muslims
sharia brooks no separation between
spiritual life and civil society
it is a comprehensive framework for
human life
dictating all matters of life from the
great
matters of government economy and combat
down to such personal matters as uh
contact between the sexes and even
matters of personal hygiene
sharia means to rule both believers and
non-believers
and it quite affirmatively sanctions
jihad in order to bring this rule about
that is the islam that exists
even if it is not the only construction
of islam it is absurd to claim
that it is not a mainstream
interpretation of islam
the mainstream interpretation in many
parts of the world
about a year ago americans were
horrified
by the beheadings of three western
journalists by the islamic state
the terror network that's now rampaging
through iraq and syria
american and european politicians could
not get to microphones fast enough
to tell us that these decapitations had
nothing to do with islam
what they failed to mention was that
within the same time
frame of a couple of weeks the
government of saudi arabia
had executed eight people by chopping
their heads off
the reason was for various violations of
sharia sharia being
the law of saudi arabia so this is not
about jihadists
it's about islam
three weeks before christmas a jihadist
couple
one american citizen the son of
pakistani immigrants
and his pakistani wife who had been
welcomed into our country on a fiance
visa
carried out a jihadist mass murder in
san bernardino california
killing 14 innocent people yet
just as was the case in fort hood where
a patent jihadist who had infiltrated
the united states army
killed 13 innocents mostly his fellow
soldiers
our government hesitated to call the the
attack
a terrorist attack why
our investigators are good at what they
do and our top officials may be
ideological
but they are not stupid why is it that
upon seeing two plus two
they can't call it four when islam is
involved
the reason is simple though frightening
stubbornly unwilling to deal with the
reality of islam as it is
our leaders have constructed an islam of
their very own
the logic of it if you can call it that
goes something like this
the government denies that terrorism is
caused by islamic doctrine
this triumph of willful of willful
blindness and political correctness
over common sense was best illustrated
by former british home secretary
jackie smith she might as well have been
speaking for our government
when she branded terrorism as
anti-islamic activity
that is the savagery is not merely
unrelated to islam
it becomes just by dint of its being
violence
contrary to islam this must be so
because the british government like the
united states government
insists that islam is a religion of
peace
of course this is preposterous as we've
seen
there are various ways of interpreting
islam to attempt to nullify
its call to violence in the scriptures
but there will always be a large
percentage of muslims who believe the
scriptures mean
exactly what they say and a large number
of influential scholars like the blind
sheikh
who will assure them that this is the
case
our government is in denial of this
unwilling to deal with islam
as it is the government must construct
its own more congenial islam
regardless of the abundance of evidence
to the contrary the government holds
that islam
is a religion of peace case closed
such a laughable case must be closed as
we've seen
because it cannot withstand scrutiny
in our government's alternative universe
terrorism committed by people who happen
to be muslim
is not in any way a reflection of any
legitimate interpretation of islam
even if islamic supremacist ideology
which endorses
jihadist violence is so mainstream that
tens of millions of muslims adhere to it
remember to the governments of the west
the fact that it is violence
makes it anti-islamic so what are the
policy implications
of governments con constructing its own
fantasy islam
totally content free except for its
being relentlessly peaceful
here are a few of the worst it means
that islamic doctrine can never be cited
as the cause of terrorism this leads for
example
to the government's hand ringing over
what it calls radicalization
you were supposed to believe that young
people all of whom just happened to be
muslim
spontaneously become violent radicals
as if there were no doctrine no body of
thought that was inducing the
radicalization
you are only to say that they have been
radicalized
you are never to ask radicalized
by what fantasy islam
also leads to the irrational decree that
terrorist organizations such as the
islamic state and al qaeda are not
islamic
you are to conclude that they are either
wanton killers or they have hijacked or
perverted islam
into something that it is not something
that cannot be dignified with the name
islam because after all
islam is a religion of peace
the most ludicrous fallout of this line
of thinking
is the apparent inability of government
officials to call mass murder attacks by
muslims
terrorist attacks but again if you
follow the government's official party
line
you understand the reluctance of these
officials
the only terrorists the government
acknowledges are terrorists
that are members of formally designated
terrorist groups
isis al-qaeda hamas hezbollah
again the government figures it's safe
to call these outfits terrorists because
it has pronounced them to be
anti-islamic thus if the police come
upon a mass murder attack
that is clearly instigated by islamic
doctrine
they are not permitted to conclude that
it is terrorism
because they've been directed to
maintain that islam is against terrorism
the agents believe they cannot call
terrorism terrorism
unless and until they un cover evidence
proving that muslim mass murderers have
some tie to a designated terrorist
organization such as isis or al-qaeda
it is rare for such evidence to be
uncovered early in an investigation
and the fact of the matter is such
evidence often does not exist
it will frequently turn out that the
muslims who've committed the atrocity
have been radicalized by islamic
supremacist
doctrine that's ubiquitously available
on the internet
and in too many local mosques and
islamic community centers
these mostly young recruits don't need
instruction from al qaeda
or isis they already share the same
ideology as these groups
the goal of imposing sharia all they
really need in order to execute
terrorist attacks
is paramilitary training and that is
readily available
you do not need to go to syria to get it
notice that there is a treacherous flip
side to our government's insistence
on making up its own content-free
obsessively peaceful islam
not only can terrorism never be
associated with it
anyone who is publicly associated with
islam by the government
must be deemed peaceful this is how we
fall into the trap of allowing the
muslim brotherhood
the world's most influential islamic
supremacist organization
to infiltrate the policy-making organs
of government counter-terrorism
the government particularly under the
control of president obama
acknowledges the brotherhood as an
islamic organization
notwithstanding the ham-handed attempt
by officials in the intelligence
community a few years back
to rebrand the brotherhood as largely
secular
under the government's imaginary islam
acknowledging a group as islamic
gives them a clean bill of health they
are deemed peaceful
and moderate they are deemed to be
steadfastly opposed to terrorism
and never you mind that hamas is the
muslim brotherhood's palestinian branch
that the brotherhood has a long history
of terrorist violence
and that the major brotherhood figures
that we have become most familiar with
have actually gone on to play leading
roles in terrorist organizations like al
qaeda
the beautiful thing about making up an
islam of their very own
is that government officials never let
the facts
get in the way of a good story the
treacherous thing
about living in an alternative universe
though is that it is just that
a story in the real world
we must deal with the reality of islamic
supremacism
because its jihadist legions have every
intention
of dealing with us we can defeat them
but only if we resolve to see them for
what they really are
thank you very much
yeah sure
thank you
uh
rather than
so i'm sure that we're we're dealing
with the same thing i want could you
tell me the last five ones in the united
states
you know the last five buddhist acts of
terrorism
well islam is not an american ideology
so
what what are the last the last five
buddhist ones how about hindu ones you
have the last five hindu
acts of terrorism how about here
well i was talking about islamic
ideology inspiring terrorism you've
chosen to broaden it i'm happy to do
that but i was wondering if you could
right okay that's a different topic than
what we're talking about
uh probably because you couldn't name
five acts of terrorism committed by any
other
by yes exactly right my interest is
is american national security you may
have broader interest in that
what i'm addressing is american national
security and the threat of islamic
terrorism
and if your position is that because
there are other threats
that could inspire terrorism we can't
consider the main threat that inspires
terrorism then i don't think we can
protect the country but we can certainly
you know have long conversations about
it
sir
um when you successfully
prosecuted the blind shake as i recall
he was sentenced to a number of
consecutive life terms and was sent out
to the super max
in colorado i think that's right did i
just did i want he was sentenced to one
life term plus some additional time but
yes
he was sent out to the super max in
colorado well right or wrong the blind
shake is a different
uh has different considerations than
other terrorists largely because we have
a very humane
prison system and because he has
particular maladies that other prisoners
don't have he has to be in a place where
where those can be medically addressed
and the the facilities are not the same
from place to place now mind you by the
way i've been out of the government for
you know 13 14 years so but thanks
the point of the question is this didn't
you recently write about how
even from prison that the the folks that
have been convicted
can manipulate can control
and can operate
um in spite of the fact that they're
they're incarcerated
yes is that's you i think you just wrote
i did
just yesterday because president obama
has proposed yet again closing
guantanamo bay so one of the
things that came up in the back and
forth of that discussion
is his insistence that
our civilian prison system
uh is just as effective against
terrorism
as guantanamo bay and offshore military
base could be and what i pointed out and
this is not
uh speculation about what could happen
based on
you know common sense this is actual
empirical
evidence that we have we have had a long
history of terrorist attacks being
plotted from prison
of imprisoned terrorist inspiring
terrorist attacks
and fomenting the fundraising for
terrorism and recruitment for terrorism
the world trade center attack of 1993
was plotted from
saeed no series captivity in attica
prison
after the trade center attack uh the
trade center bombers who were convicted
to life
were nevertheless able to correspond
with jihadists
in spain some of whom were uh
responsible for terrorist attacks
uh in europe uh osama bin laden
credited the blind sheikh with issuing
the fatwa which is the sharia
edict approving the 911 attacks
which he did from prison after he was
sentenced
to life in prison that was
super max where he was at the time and
in fact
um lynn stewart his attorney
uh was convicted of material support to
terrorism
for uh for facilitating the blind shake
in communicating messages from his
prison captivity to his terrorist
organization
including telling them that a truce that
he had with mubarak was
was off so there is a considerable
history
of terrorists once they're in american
prisons continuing to participate
in terrorist activity
yes sir
um i've always assumed that i mean i've
been aware i've read your writings and
so forth and i've been aware that the
american officials are are saying that
uh
islam is a religion of peace now i have
always thought that they would know
better
but they're only saying it for political
reasons namely they don't want to
relocalize their own
they want to marginalize their own
populations muslim populations this is
especially true in britain because they
have a lot of them
now i mean i was wondering if you're
implying that these people were
believing their own propaganda and
actually believe that islam is a
religion of peace now i'm sure that none
of these people read the quran
and actually do their own research and
so forth so they're just reflexively
saying this for political reasons that's
always been my take and i'm wondering
what you think of that
well as i said at the beginning of my
remarks if i put them in my shoes
back in 1993 when i first got involved
in this
i believed it because i wanted to
believe it
and because i didn't have a lot of
information until i rolled up my sleeves
and learned so i think there are
a number of people who simply aren't
that familiar with
islamic doctrine and islamic scripture
who who choose to believe something they
would rather believe than
have an informed opinion but let's stick
with people who have an informed opinion
because hopefully that's most of our
policymakers i've always thought that
there are
a few different reasons why
people misrepresent what they know to be
the truth about islamic ideology and
it's
it's literal the literal roots of
islamic supremacism in it and when i
talk about islamic supremacism i'm
again talking about the ideology that
says that sharia has to govern
sharia is the uh is deemed in this
ideology to be the
necessary precondition to islamizing a
society
so that's the that's the goal um
so why do they why do they deny that's
the case
i think with respect to some they are
under the uh
the good faith but i think simply wrong
delusionally wrong
idea that um if we acknowledge the
connection
between islamic scripture and violence
then we will be seen as being at war
with all
muslims and that that's an unacceptable
outcome now it seems to me we should be
able to walk and chew gum at the same
time we should be able to say
you know islam is a big ideology there's
a lot of different ways of
interpreting it and what we're concerned
about are islamists
who want to supplant the constitution
many of whom are violent
jihadist and i don't see why you can't
acknowledge that because it's reality
um without uh saying
with the same broad brush that all
muslims are evil because that's not
where
anybody is coming from at least that i
uh that i know
um so i think those people are simply
wrong
then i think there are others who for
example
want to embrace and engage
outfits like the muslim brotherhood and
even the republic
of the government in tehran
on the theory which i think is misguided
and another one of those theories that's
forever
chasing after evidence to to prove the
truth of it
that if you take people who are
comparatively moderate and the only way
you could find the muslim brotherhood to
be moderate is if you compare it to isis
i mean otherwise they're
they're quite radical but the idea would
be
if you treat people like regular actors
they will somehow become
regular rational political actors so if
we cultivate the muslim brotherhood it
will become a progressive force
in islam even if it isn't one so much
now
and if you treat the islamic government
in
iran as if it were a normal rational
government
and you bring it and give it a seat at
the table it will become a normal
rational
government over time uh i think they
believe that
in good faith i think it's uh i think
it's
contrary to everything we know about
human nature in human history but i
don't doubt their good faith
in believing it and then finally i think
there's a cynical political aspect
to this as well and even though i don't
want to get overly
political i think this is more common on
the left than
any place else and that is that if you
deny
that islamic ideology and in particular
islamic supremacist ideology
is the cause of terrorism then
well something has to cause it so what
do you fill that blank in with
and it turns out in in in this cynical
corner
what they fill the blank in with is
israel
or military commissions or detention
without trial
or i've even seen global warming
blame for uh for terrorism but the point
is that it's a powerful
rhetorical tool to say that the things
that you are against politically
as a matter of policy are not only bad
but actually are the cause of
mass murder attacks and i think i don't
think anybody really
believes such nonsense but they do say
it um
president obama is saying yesterday that
you know
guantanamo bay having it open causes
terrorism it drives
terrorist recruitment that's the most
preposterous argument that you could
conceivably make he's been making it
since
his first day in office i will tell you
for example
i prosecuted the guy as i as i've just
described
who got the nice civilian trial with the
grade a due process and then got sent to
every nice
prison facility you know the civilian
prisons not bad
bush's gulag at guantanamo bay the you
know the nice pristine federal prisons
there have been multiple mass murder
attacks
committed by jihadists to try to extort
the united states into releasing the
blind shake including one
in luxor egypt where 64 people were mass
murdered in
1997 or 1998.
anybody with common sense who looks at
this problem
understands that even americans
don't know the at by and large
don't know the constitutional niceties
that divide the people who have been
prosecuted under the due process
standards of civilian justice versus the
laws of war in military proceedings uh
if americans don't know that why on
earth would we think
the people we're trying to influence
overseas would know that they don't care
where we detain terrorists they care
that we detain terrorists and it doesn't
make any difference to them
whether it's guantanamo bay or any place
else
that doesn't mean that the things they
object to
will not be used pretextually to justify
their atrocities but i think we should
remain mindful of the fact that what's
driving the atrocities is their ideology
not the pretext
thank you very much for an enlightening
presentation uh
do you know of any credible muslim
initiatives to reform islam
yeah there are actually quite a number
of them
i think zoody jasser
expressly refers to himself as a
reformer
and he's worked very hard to try to
more broaden in a more popular way
an interpretation of islam that
nullifies
the jihadist command i think you know
part of the problem
that that he has and that a lot of
reformers have
is that they're not islamic scholars
judy zuty's a doctor but he's a medical
doctor he's not a doctor of islamic
jurisprudence
and this is very dangerous business
for these guys because in the
supremacist interpretation of islam that
is actually mainstream islam
in the middle east departure
from scholarly consensus is deemed to be
apostasy
which is a death penalty offense so when
a lot of people hear the reformers who
are in this
culture they think that they're
committing profound sin which
certainly hurts their credibility right
um
and and you know it's important to
understand that a lot of the um
a lot of the debate that we've had about
free speech and the
the intersection between free speech and
islam
would lead the person the common person
looking
at or watching the debate to believe
that the problem is that sharia
um prohibits insults
to islam you know insulting depictions
of the prophet
uh things like the muslim equivalent of
piss christ that
you know to any any believer in in
christianity would be
offensive um it's unfortunate that
that's the context of
the debate because i think even those of
us who believe
fervently in free expression
at some level think that our discourse
would not be
compromised in any material way if that
kind of
expression were forbidden even though in
the back of our minds we know it's a
dangerous slippery slope to
to forbid insult because the next thing
we're into what's really an insult and
what's political
discussion etc that distorts
the threat that sharia standards pose
for american first amendment principles
because in sharia
it's not just insults to islam that are
forbidden
expression it's actually anything that
departs from scholarly consensus
anything that subjects islam to critical
examination
anything that could cast islam in an
unflattering
light or anything that could so discord
in the uma which is the the global
islamic community
so if you think about that um
this this discussion that we're having
today
could not take place in many parts of
the middle east
where sharia is the law because we
wouldn't be
able we wouldn't be allowed to conduct
the conversation we're having a critical
examination
of islam one more thing on your on your
question
um i know that ayan hersey ali who is an
apostate
um has recently changed her view
i know it only i reviewed her new book
uh
a few months back for the new criterion
um she
she was of the view up until fairly
recently i think
um that islam was a lost cause and she's
actually become
i think she would tell you herself that
she's become hostile not just a
islam but to other religious faiths
in general um i don't want to put words
in her mouth but i think
that's a fair analysis of our position
she now takes the position that islam is
salvageable
but there would be certain very
difficult things to do that would have
to be done in order to reform it
in an effective way including departing
from the example of muhammad and
um taking him down several pegs in the
the pantheon of important
muslim theological principles if that's
the only way it can be reformed
i don't want to say that it can never
happen but
it's not going to happen in my lifetime
that's for sure
yes sir
quick question why didn't uh the blind
shake
uh and say something like ksm get the
death penalty
the blind shake didn't get the death
penalty because the
um there was there was a federal
pause in the death penalty that went on
for i want to say
close to 20 years arising out of the
furman case
i think by 1993
we were back the federal government was
back in the death penalty
business but everything was in flux at
the time that the world trade center
was born and also to be to be
uh perfectly frank the case
implicating the blind shake in the
actual
conspiracy to bomb the world trade
center is
i thought it was a strong circumstantial
case but it's a circumstantial case and
in the to to be clear about it
we based the case on on basically
two different plots in 1993
with a lot of background information
before then about how the
how the enterprise formed up um
but the trade center was attacked in
february late february
of 93 and then instantly they were on to
another
plot which was known as the landmarks
plot this plot
to take out these new york city
landmarks in the second plot we had very
solid evidence of the blind shake on
tape
commanding you know look for a plan to
bomb an american military
installation so we had charges
um we had very strong evidence of him
involved in a terrorist plot
the evidence involving him
the evidence proving that he was the
formulating figure
in the cell that clearly carried out the
world trade center attack
was overwhelming the evidence that he
knew about the trade center attack
and approved it was there but it was
circumstantial
so even if we had the death penalty i
think it it probably would not be the
kind of a case that the justice
department would approve
the death penalty for uh ksm is another
matter ksm could get the death penalty
as i understand it
in in the military commission
um i i for what it's worth
working terrorism cases made me a lot
more
um firm in
uh approving the death penalty than i
had been
before um i actually got an opportunity
a few years back to teach
a constitutional criminal law course
a couple of semesters and it's funny
when you when you
sit down you know when when you're
dealing with things as a prosecutor
issues come at you based on what the
exigencies of the case are they don't
come at in any program
way and when you have to try to teach
this stuff you actually have to sit down
and
and you know go through the cases and
the principles in an orderly way
and the interesting thing you discover
when you do that with with
constitutional criminal law issues
is that almost every place where the law
gets screwed up the criminal law gets
screwed up
um it's a death penalty case and it's
usually
because courts are tend to be hostile to
the death penalty
if the death penalty part of the case is
bulletproof and there's nothing they
could do really to undo it
they will find other reasons they'll
scrub the record for other reasons to
not allow the death penalty to be
imposed
so a lot of cases where the law gets bad
for the government
in terms of you know various things that
you're now required to do
in the way of uh of criminals rights are
because of the death penalty
so i i was never crazy about the idea of
the government
um being in control of the
instrumentalities of death
uh largely because i worked for the
government for 25 years and i
saw how screwed up things can be so you
know at least the other
other decisions i was involved in most
of those were reversible death penalty
isn't
um but my my main opposition my main
problem with the death penalty was just
um i didn't think it was with the number
of executions that you do
compared to the burden that it imposes
on the system
uh and the and the burden it imposes
because the precedence and death
penalty cases get opposed get applied to
all the cases i didn't think it was
worth it in terms of the system of
justice
but when i work national security cases
when you see the blind shake issue with
fatwa from prison and 3 000 people get
killed
you realize at a certain point that
there is no way to neutralize
a certain kind of heinous offender
other than the death penalty because if
you don't take him out of
commission you're endangering a lot of
innocent people
thank you andrew for a great uh great
luck well thank you so much thank you
very much
thank you all for coming i will just
mention uh two things in in passing
upcoming
uh on march 17th uh greg gianforte will
be here
he is a very successful entrepreneur in
montana actually running for governor
there who wrote a book on bootstrapping
your business
he's going to talk about um the future
of entrepreneurship
in a bureaucratic america and then on
march 22nd
david whalen the provost of hillsdale
college will be here to talk about his
take
and our take on the question of free
speech on college campus
thank you all for coming